lawyers do not ask questions they do not
already know the answers to no guy most
guys don't propose to someone without
already know the person's gonna say yes
the take rate on proposals is very high
most girls say yes to a proposal and
sales should be the same way if you feel
like you don't think you're going to
close this person do not pitch them
continue to stay in this circle where
you are asking questions and reinstating
and clarifying until you can eventually
find that piece that thread that was
unexposed that you need to pull to then
get them to say that aha that's the
issue and so from this the three things
that you should be using when you're
closing is you should be asking
questions you should be restating what
they said and then once you've exhausted
these pieces where it becomes obvious
that you need to move on the sale only
at that point they'll say well how do i
work with you how does the program work
they should be asking you or you can at
the very least say would you like to
know the programmers i think it might be
a good fit for you at that point they
can give you permission to say yes you
do not pitch the program until you
believe the person will say yes